[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
ERIK DEMAINE: All right, welcome
back to data structures land.
Today we continue and complete
our segment on binary trees.
So this is part two.
If you missed part one, go
back and watch part one.
Last time, we talked about
binary trees in general.
We had each node stored an
item, and also a left pointer
and a right pointer
to other nodes,
and a parent pointer
to another node.
This was an example of a tree.
B, and C are A's children.
A is the parent of B
and C, and also the root
of the entire tree.
We defined the height of a node.
We didn't use this too much yet.
But we're going to
use it a lot today.
So remember, the height
is as drawn in red here.
Height of the node is the length
of the longest downward path
counting edges.
So B, for example,
has a length 2 paths.
So we write a 2 here.
You can also think
of it as if you just
live within the subtree
rooted at B, B subtree,
then what is the maximum
depth of those nodes,
if you prefer to think
about it that way.
Either way is fine.
And in particular,
we distinguished
h, the height of the
root node, as the height
of the entire tree.
And what we achieved
last time was basically
all of our operations
ran in order h time.
So we had subtree insert,
subtree delete, subtree first
and last.
We could compute the
predecessor and successor
of a node, all in order h time.
So as long as h was
small, we were happy.
And remember, what does
predecessor and successor mean?
It's talking about an implicit
order in the tree, which
is what we call traversal order,
which is defined recursively
as recursively traverse the left
subtree, then output the root,
then recursively traverse
the right subtree.
So in this example, the
traversal order is F is the--
if you go all the way
left, that was the first
in the traversal order.
Then we have-- right, I'll
make me some space here.
Then we have D,
then we have B. Then
we do the right
subtree of B, which
is E. Then we have the
root, because we finished
the left subtree of the root.
So that's A. And then we have C.
So there's an implicit linear
order encoded by this tree.
And the whole point
of binary trees
is that we can efficiently
update the tree much faster
than we could explicitly write
down an order in an array
or something like that.
So binary trees let us quickly--
now, quickly is not
so quick right now.
Because everything is order h.
And in the worst
case, h is linear.
Because we can have
a tree like this.
But today, we're going
to make-- we're going
to guarantee that h is log n.
And so the goal of
today is to take
all of these operations
that run in order h time
and get them to run an
order log n time, just
by modifying the data
structure we've already seen.
So we've done a lot of the
hard work, just a little bit
more work we need to do
today on something called
AVL trees or height balance.
But before we get there, I want
to talk a little bit more--
at the very end of
the last lecture,
we talked about once you have
these subtree operations--
so I can insert and
delete in the subtree--
how do I actually use that to
solve the problems that we care
about in this class, which are
sequence data structure and set
data structure?
So we talked mostly about the
set data structure last time.
So in general, we're going to
define what traversal order
we maintain by a binary tree.
And so for a set, because
for the set interface,
we're interested in doing
queries like find_next
and find_previous, given
a key, if it's not there,
tell me the previous
one or the next one,
this is something we could
do with binary search.
And so the big, cool thing
that binary trees let us do,
if we let the traversal order
always be all of the items
stored in increasing
key order, then we
are effectively maintaining
the items in order--
in the traversal order sense.
Again, we're not explicitly
maintaining them in order.
But up here, we're
maintaining a tree that
represents items in key order.
And so this lets us do a
subtree_find operation--
which you could easily
use to implement find,
and find_previous, and so on--
as follows.
We start at the
root of the tree.
So we can say, node
equals root initially.
And then we can recursively
search for a key k as follows.
We check, well, if
the item at the root
has a key that's bigger than k--
let me draw a little picture.
So we're at some node here.
This is a node.
And it has left subtree
and a right subtree.
And there's some
item with some key.
So if the key we're looking for
is less than the node's item,
that means it's down
here in the left subtree.
And so we recurse on node.left.
If they're equal, that
means that this item
is the item we're looking for.
So we can just return
it or the node,
depending on what
you're looking for.
And if the key in here
is greater than the key
we're looking for, then
we'll recurse to the right.
If you think about
it a little bit,
this is exactly binary
search on an array.
It just happens to
be on a tree instead.
If you think of an
array like this,
what does binary search do?
It first looks at the
key in the middle.
I'm going to draw
that as the root.
And then, it recurses
either on the left chunk,
which I will draw recursively,
or on the right chunk.
And so if you happen to
have a perfect binary
tree like this one, it
is simulating exactly
binary search in this array.
But this we're going to be able
to maintain dynamically-- not
perfect any more, but close.
Whereas this we could not
maintain in sorted order.
So this is like a
generalization of binary search
to work on trees
instead of on arrays.
And for this reason, set binary
trees are called binary search
trees, because they're the
tree version of binary search.
So there's many
equivalent names.
So binary search tree is another
name for set binary tree.
And the key thing that
makes this algorithm work is
the so-called binary
search tree property, which
is all the keys in the
left subtree of a node
are less than the
root, or of that node,
and that key is less than all
the keys in the right subtree.
And this is true recursively
all the way down.
And so that's how you prove
that this algorithm is
correct by this property.
Why is this true?
Because if we can
maintain traversal order
to be increasing
key, then that's
exactly what
traversal order means.
It tells you all the things
in the left subtree come
before the root, which
come before all the things
in the right subtree.
So this property
implies this one.
And how do you maintain things
in increasing key order?
It's pretty easy.
If you want to insert an
item, where does it belong?
Well, you do this
search to find where it
would belong if it was there.
If it's there, you can overwrite
the value stored with that key.
If it's not, this
search will fall off
the tree at some
point, and that's
where you insert a
new node in your tree.
That was covered in recitation,
so I don't want to dwell on it.
What I want to focus on today
is the other application.
How do we-- this is for
representing a set, which
is relatively easy.
A challenge to sort of
set ourselves up for,
but we need a
little more work, is
to make sequence binary trees.
So suppose I have a binary
tree, and what I would like--
we mentioned at the
end of last time--
is that I want the
traversal order of my tree
to be the sequence
order, the order that I'm
trying to represent that's
changed by operations
like insert_at.
So I'd just like to
do the same thing.
But now, I have to think
about how do I do a search,
how do I do a insert_at,
that sort of thing.
And here is an algorithm for
what I would like to work.
But it's not going
to quite work yet.
So suppose I give you a
subtree, so specified by a node.
So there's all the
descendants of that node.
And I'd like to know what
is in the traversal order
of that subtree, which
starts here, and ends here,
and the root will be
somewhere in the middle.
Give me the ith node.
So if I ask i equals
0, I want to get
this leftmost descendant.
If I ask for i equals the
size of the tree minus 1,
I want to get the
rightmost descendant.
That was the first and
last in the subtree
that we talked about.
But we know how to find
the first and last.
Just walk left or walk right.
But we don't know how
to find the ith node--
in order h time is the
goal right now, not log n.
And the idea is, well, it
seems like size matters.
[CHUCKLES] Sorry if
you heard otherwise.
So in particular,
I mentioned size
when I was talking about the
last node in the sequence.
The index of that node is
size of the subtree minus 1.
So let's define
the size of a node
to be the number of
nodes in its subtree--
we were calling
that subtree(node)--
including the node itself.
So if I somehow
knew the size, this
seems important for
understanding indexes.
Let's just assume that
I knew that magically
in constant time.
Then, I claim that the
size of the left subtree--
so why don't I expand
this diagram a little bit?
So we have node as before.
But we have left subtree
and a right subtree.
So this node here is node.left.
This node here is node.right.
They might not exist, but let's
ignore those exceptional cases
for now.
Let's suppose we knew not
only the size of node,
but we knew the
size of node.left,
so that is the size of
this tree on the left.
I'm going to call that nL.
So let's suppose that there
are nL nodes down here.
I claim that lets me do the
equivalent of a binary search.
Because I'm looking
for some index i.
And if i is less than nL, then I
know that it must be down here.
For example, if i
equals 0, it's going
to be in the left subtree, as
long as nL is greater than 0,
right?
So that's exactly this check.
If i is less than nL,
I'm going to recurse
to the left, call subtree
at of node.left, i.
That's what's written here.
If i equals nL, if you think
about it for a second-- so nL
is the number of nodes here.
And so that means this
node has index nL.
The index of this node is nL.
And so if i equals-- if the
one index we're looking for
is that one, then we
just return this node.
We're done.
And otherwise, i
is greater than nL.
And that means that the
node we're looking for
is in the right subtree,
because it comes after the root.
Again, that's what it means.
That's what traversal
order means.
So if we define it
to be sequence order,
then we know all the things
that come after this node, which
is index nL, must be over here.
Now when we recurse down here,
our numbering system changes.
Because for node, 0 is here.
And then for node.right is here.
So we need to do a little bit
of subtraction here, which
is when we recurse
to the right, we
take i minus nL minus 1--
minus nL for these guys,
minus 1 for the root node.
And that will give us
the index we're looking
for within this subtree.
So my point is, this
algorithm is basically
the same as this algorithm.
But this one uses keys, because
we're dealing with a set,
and in sets we assume
items have keys.
Over here, items don't
have to have keys.
In fact, we're not
touching the items at all.
We're just asking, what is the
ith item in my sequence, which
is the same thing as what is the
ith item in my traversal order,
which is the same thing
as asking what is the ith
node in the traversal order?
And this algorithm
gives it to you
exactly the same
way in order h time.
Now, I'm not going to show
you all the operations.
But you can use subtree_at
to implement get_at set_at.
You just find the appropriate
node and return the item
or modify the item.
Or you can use it to--
most crucially, you can use
it to do insert_at delete_at.
This is a new thing we've
never been able to do before.
What do you do?
Just like over here, if I'm
trying to insert an item,
I search for that
item over here.
So if I'm trying to insert at
i, for example, I look for i.
And then for insert_at i,
want to add a new item just
before that one.
And conveniently,
we already have--
I didn't mention, but we
have a subtree insert.
We had two versions--
before and after.
I think we covered after,
which I use successor
before I use predecessor.
But we can just
call subtree insert
before at that node, and
boom, we will have added
a new item just before it.
And great, so
magically, somehow, we
have inserted in the
middle of this sequence.
And all of the indices update,
because I'm not storing
indices.
Instead, to search for
an item at index i,
I'm using the search algorithm.
But there's a problem.
What's the problem?
This seems a little
too good to be true.
I insert in the
middle of this tree,
and then somehow, I can
magically search and still
find the ith item, even though
all the indices to the right
of that item incremented by 1.
It's almost true.
Answer?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Because we have
to update the sizes, right.
I didn't say, how do I compute
the size of the left subtree?
So that is the next topic.
We're almost done.
This will actually work.
It's really quite awesome.
But for it to work,
we need something
called subtree
augmentation, which
I'll talk about generally.
And then, we'll
apply it to size.
So the idea with
subtree augmentation
is that each node
in our binary tree
can store a constant
number of extra fields.
Why not?
And in particular,
if these fields
are of a particular type--
maybe I'll call them properties.
I'm going to define
a subtree property
to be something
that can be computed
from the properties of
the nodes' children.
So I should say
this is of a node.
So children are
node.left and node.right.
You can also access constant
amount of other stuff,
for example the node itself.
But the point of
a subtree property
is it's downward looking.
If I have a node
here, and I want
to compute some
property about it--
call it, we want to
store P of the node--
and suppose we already
know P over here,
the property computed
for the left subtree
or for the left
node, and we already
know the property for the
right node, then what I'd like
is for this to be
computable in constant time.
So I can compute P of this
node given P of the left node
and P of the right node.
That's a subtree property.
Now, in particular, size
is a substrate property.
Why?
Because I can write
this kind of recurrence,
node.size equals
node.left.size--
this is very tedious to write--
plus node.right.size, plus?
1, thank you.
The size of the entire
subtree here, called node,
is the size of the left subtree
plus size of the right subtree,
plus 1 for that node itself.
So this is an update rule.
It takes constant
time to evaluate.
It's two editions.
Sorry, my t's look kind
of like plus signs.
I'll make the pluses
a little bigger.
So we're just summing
those three things.
Boom, we can get node.size.
So I claim that as long as
my property has this feature,
I can maintain it dynamically
as I'm changing the tree.
Now, this is a little bit
of a forward reference,
because we haven't
said exactly how we're
going to change the tree yet.
But question?
AUDIENCE: If node.size
is recursive,
then how is it happening
in constant time?
Wouldn't it be
happening [INAUDIBLE]??
ERIK DEMAINE: Why is this--
OK, good question.
So one natural
way, you can think
of this as a recursion,
which gives you
a recursive algorithm.
So I wrote-- but
didn't write it.
But I could have written
size of node equals this--
size of node.left
plus-- and that
would give you a linear time
algorithm to count the size.
And if you don't
have any information,
that is what you would do.
And that would be very painful.
So that would make this
algorithm really slow.
If I'm calling size as a
recursive function, it's bad.
What I'm instead doing
is storing the sizes
on every single node
and pre-computing this.
So in fact, I'm going to
define the size of node in--
so this is the definition
mathematically.
But the algorithm
for this function
is just going to be
return node.size.
So that's constant time.
So the challenge now is I
have to keep these sizes up
to date, no matter
what I do to the tree.
And you could look
back at last lecture
and see, OK, what were all the
changes that I did in a tree?
We only did changes
during insert and delete.
And I will just claim to you,
when we did insert and delete,
what they ended up
doing in the end,
they add or remove
a leaf of the tree.
Remember, a leaf was a
node with no children.
So let's just think about if
I add a new leaf in a tree--
here's a tree, suppose
I add a leaf here--
which subtrees change?
Well, which subtrees
contain that node?
It is its own new subtree.
Then it's in its parent subtree,
and its grandparent subtree,
and the overall subtree.
In general, these nodes
are called the ancestors
of this node that we added.
And those are the
ones that update.
This subtree over
here didn't change.
It didn't change size.
And because it's a
subtree property,
no subtree property
will change over here,
because the subtree
was untouched.
So when I touch this
guy, I just have
to update the subtree
property here,
update the subtree
update subtree property here.
How many of these are there?
Yeah?
h-- I'll say order h to be safe.
But I think it's exactly h.
So also, when I remove
a leaf, the same thing--
if I remove this leaf,
then the subtrees
that change are exactly
its former ancestors.
Cool, so we're going
to update those order h
ancestors in order up the tree.
So what do I mean by update?
I mean apply this rule.
For size, it's this rule.
But in general, the
subtree property
gives me an update rule
that takes constant time.
And so I'm going to
apply that update rule
to this node, which will fix
whatever property is stored
in there.
Maybe there's more
than one property.
And then I'll apply
it to this node.
And because this is already
correct by induction,
and this is already correct
because I didn't touch this
subtree-- it's unchanged--
then I can update the
value at this node--
the property at this
node in constant time.
Then I update this one.
And because this one is
already correct by induction,
and this one is already
correct because this subtree is
unchanged, I can update
the property correctly here
in constant time.
So when I make a
change in order h time,
because I'm making h calls to
this constant time algorithm,
I can update a constant
number of subtree properties.
This is very powerful.
Data structure augmentation
is super useful.
You will use it on
your problem set.
We will use it again today.
Let me give you some examples
of subtree properties.
They could be-- common ones are,
like, the sum, or the product,
or the min, or the
max, or sum of squares,
or all sorts of
things, of some feature
of every node in the subtree.
In fact, subtree size is
an example of such a thing.
It is the sum over all nodes
in the subtree of the value 1.
It's another way to say
count the number of nodes.
But you could also
say, what's the sum
of the keys in these nodes?
Or you could say, what's the
maximum key in these nodes?
Or you could say, what is the
maximum value in these nodes?
You can take any property.
It doesn't have to be key.
It doesn't have to be
anything in particular.
It's very powerful.
You can take all sums,
products and maintain them
as long as they're
downward looking--
as long as you're only
thinking about the subtree.
Some examples of things
you cannot maintain are--
not a nodes index.
So if you get a little bit too
excited about augmentation,
you might think, oh,
I could do everything.
I needed to support
subtree_at, or let's
just say, get_at
globally, I wanted
to know what is the
ith node in my tree?
Well, I'll just use data
structure augmentation
and store in every node what is
its index, 0 through n minus 1.
I can't maintain
that efficiently.
Because if I insert
at the beginning
of my traversal order, then
all the indices change.
So that's an example of a edit.
So if I insert a
new node over here,
so this guy's index
was 0, now it's 1.
This guy's index
was 1, now it's 2.
This was 2, now
it's 3, and so on.
Every node changes its index.
Index is not a subtree
property, and that's
why we can't maintain it.
Because it depends on all
of the nodes in the tree.
Or it depends on all
the nodes to its left--
all the predecessors.
So for example, this
guy's index depends
on how many nodes are over
here on the left, which is not
in the subtree of that node.
So that's where you
have to be careful.
Don't use global
properties of the tree.
You can only use
subtree properties.
Another example is depth.
Depth Is annoying to maintain,
but it's not obvious why yet.
We will see that in a moment.
The rest of today is about
going from order h order log
n, which is what this
slide is showing us.
So at this point, you should
believe that we can do all
of the sequence data structure
operations in order h time--
except for build and iterate,
which take linear time--
and that we can do all of the
set operations in order h time,
except build and
iterate, which take
n log n and n respectively.
And our goal is to
now bound h by log n.
We know it's possible
at some level,
because there are trees that
have logarithmic height.
That's like this
perfect tree here.
But we also know we
have to be careful,
because there are some bad
trees, like this chain.
So if h equals log n, we call
this a balanced binary tree.
There are many
balanced binary trees
in the world, maybe
a dozen or two--
a lot of different
data structures.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
you said not
to think about things
on a global level
so we'll think of
them [INAUDIBLE]..
Can you explain what
that means a little more?
ERIK DEMAINE: OK,
what does it mean
for a property to be local
to a subtree versus global?
The best answer is
this definition.
But that's maybe not the
most intuitive definition.
This is what I mean.
Something that can be computed
just knowing information
about your left
and right children,
that is the meaning
of such a property.
And those are the only things
you're allowed to maintain.
Because those are
the only things
that are easy to update
by walking up this path.
And the contrast is that
global property like index,
it's global, in
particular, because I
can do one change, add one
node, and all of the node's
properties change.
So that's an extreme
example of global.
We want this very
particular notion of local,
because that's what we can
actually afford to recompute.
Hopefully that clarifies.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't size not
work with that [INAUDIBLE]??
ERIK DEMAINE: You're
right that if we added--
oh, no.
OK, let's think about that.
If we added a new
parent to the tree--
this is not something
that we've ever done.
But even if we did that,
which subtrees change?
Only this one.
This node, it's a
totally new subtree.
But the subtree of this node
is completely unchanged.
Because subtrees are
always downward looking,
if I added a new root, I
didn't change any subtrees
except for one.
So size is a subtree property.
Now, there are--
I mean, I could completely
redraw the tree.
And that's an operation
that requires everything
to be recomputed.
So it is limited exactly what
I'm allowed to do in the tree.
But I claim everything
we'll do, last class
and today, we can afford
this augmentation.
So it's a feature, not of
all binary trees necessarily,
but of the ones
that we would cover.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What is a min?
ERIK DEMAINE: What is a min?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Binary tree, yeah.
OK, this will make a little
more sense in a moment
when I say what we're actually
going to do with trees.
We need a new tool for
manipulating a tree.
What we've done so far, we've
done some swapping of items.
And we did adding
and removing a leaf.
That's not enough.
We're going to need
something else to let us
guarantee logarithmic height.
And that something else
is called a rotation.
What does this something
else need to do?
This is just a tool for
rebalancing the tree.
So it should not change the data
that's represented by the tree.
What is the data
represented by the tree?
Traversal order.
Traversal order is sacrosanct.
We're not allowed to touch it.
It's already defined
two different ways,
depending on whether you're
using a set or sequence.
So we want to modify the
tree in a way that doesn't
modify the traversal order.
So we're exploiting redundancy.
If you wrote down the
traversal order in an array,
there's exactly
one representation
of a given order.
But in a tree, there's
many representations.
It could be a long line.
It could be a balance thing.
They could represent the
exact same order on the nodes
if you label them right.
In fact, there are exponentially
many different representations
of the same thing.
And we're going to exploit that,
the same order, and define--
this is just a thing
you need to know.
Let me label, A, X, B,
Y, C. You can tell I've
drawn this diagram
before many, many times.
This is a very powerful tool
in all tree data structures,
which are most of
data structures.
And they are called right rotate
of y and left rotate of x.
So if I have this tree--
which I'm just black
boxing some of the subtrees
into little triangles.
If I have a node, and
it has a left child,
then I'm allowed to right rotate
this edge, which means take
this edge and go like this--
90 degrees, kind of.
Or you could just think of
it as rewriting it this way.
Now, you might also have keeping
track of the parent pointer.
Parent pointer moves around.
Before, this was
the parent of y.
Now it's the parent of x.
So x and y are switching places.
But we couldn't just
swap these items around,
because that would
change traversal order.
In this picture,
x comes before y,
because x is in the left
subtree of y in traversal order.
And over here, now y is
in the right subtree of x.
So it comes after x.
So in both cases,
x comes before y.
And indeed, in all of these
pictures the traversal order--
I mean, not just for x and
y, but also for A, B, and C,
the traversal order
is consistent.
It is A, X, B, y, C, where,
when I write a triangle,
I mean recursively the
traversal order of all
the things in the triangle.
So if you just apply the
traversal order algorithm here
versus here, you
get the same output,
which means these operations
preserve traversal order.
Great, so this is
a thing that we
can do in a tree that won't
affect any of the stuff
we've done so far.
It's a tool that we
can use to rebalance.
Notice how deep things
are in the tree changes.
Our problem with
this linear tree
is that there are some
nodes of linear depth.
We want to get rid of those.
How?
Well, we could take these edges
and start rotating them up.
If you look at depths,
in this picture,
A and B are deeper than
C. And in this picture,
B and C are deeper than
A. So it's a trade off.
This one moved up.
This one moved down.
This one stayed
at the same depth.
So hopefully, if A is too
deep and C is too shallow,
they can trade off like this.
It may sound difficult,
but in fact, there's
a pretty simple way, which
are called AVL trees, that
maintain balance in a particular
way called height balance.
This is if we take the
height of node.left--
actually, I'd prefer to--
node.right, minus
height of node.left,
so this thing is called
skew of the node.
I want this to always be
minus 1, 0, or plus 1.
So this is saying that
if I have any node,
and I look if its left
subtree and its right subtree,
I measure their
heights-- remember,
that's downward distance,
maximum distance to a leaf--
I measure the height
of this tree--
maximum height-- and I
measure the maximum height
of this subtree, I want these
to be within 1 of each other.
Ideally, they're equal.
That would be the perfect case.
But let's let them differ by 1.
So maybe this is k
and this is k plus 1.
Or maybe this is k
and this is k minus 1.
In this picture, what is
the height of this node?
It's good practice.
k plus 2, good.
What's the longest path
from this node to a leaf?
Well, it could go
through this subtree.
And that would be length k
plus 1, because it's k in here
plus 1 for this edge.
Or it could be through here,
and that's k plus 1 plus 1.
So the biggest is
to go to the right.
So the height-- if I told you
the height of these subtrees,
we can derive the
height of this node.
We're going to use
that a lot in a moment.
So, the first claim
is that if I could
maintain height
balance, then I will
guarantee that h equals log n.
So in other words, height
balance implies balance.
So let's prove
that first quickly.
And then, the interesting part
is how do we actually prove--
or how do we actually
maintain the balance property?
We're going to do
that using rotations.
But how is a big question.
So why does height
balance imply balance?
So what this is saying is
that all height balanced trees
have logarithmic height.
So what I'd like
to think about is
sort of the least balanced
height balanced tree.
The least balanced one is going
to have every node a mismatch.
Let's say the left
subtree is shallower
than the right subtree by 1, and
recursively all the way down.
So every node has
a gap here, a--
what do we call it--
a skew of 1, which
I'm going to write--
I'm going to introduce
some notation.
I'll write a dissenting
rightward arrow of this one
is higher than the left subtree.
So the easy way to
think about this
is this is sort
of our worst case.
This is going to be the fewest
nodes for the maximum depth.
Let's just count how many
nodes are in this tree.
I'm going to write that
as a recurrence, which
is the number of nodes
in a tree of height h.
So if this whole tree has height
h, as we said in this picture,
if I just subtract 2
from all these numbers,
then this one has
height h minus 2,
and this one has
height h minus 1.
So how many nodes are in here?
Well, this is a recurrence
I'm going to write.
So this will be N sub h minus 2.
This will be N sub h minus 1.
And then I just count how many
nodes are in this picture.
It is Nh minus 1 plus Nh
minus 2 plus 1, or this node.
Now you might ask, what
is Nh a recurrence for?
But it is the number of nodes
in this sort of worst case
if the worst case
has total height h.
So you can also
think of it as what
is the minimum number
of nodes I could
have in an AVL tree, which is
a height balanced tree, that
has a height h in a
height balanced tree?
OK, so now I just need
to solve this recurrence.
This recurrence
look familiar-ish?
It's like Fibonacci numbers.
If I remove the plus
1, it's Fibonacci.
And if you happen to know
the Fibonacci numbers grow
as, like, a golden
ratio to the n,
then we know that
this is exponential,
which is what we want.
Because if Nh is
exponential in h,
that means h is
logarithmic in N,
because log is inverse
of exponential.
But maybe you don't know
about Fibonacci numbers.
And so we can still easily
show that this is exponential
as follows.
I want to prove that it's
at least an exponential,
because that gives me that
h is at most logarithmic.
So we need a lower bound.
And so we have these two terms
which are hard to compare--
Nh minus 1 and Nh minus 2.
It's kind of ugly.
But if we're allowed
to be sloppy--
and we'll see if
we're not too sloppy--
and still get an
exponential answer,
let's just make
them equal like so.
So this is a true statement,
in fact, strictly greater than.
Why?
Because I removed the plus 1.
That should only make
something smaller.
And I replaced Nh minus
1 with Nh minus 2.
Here, I'm implicitly
using a fact,
which is obvious by induction,
that this tree on height--
if I take this tree
versus this tree,
this one has more
nodes than this one.
If I have larger height,
this construction
is going to build a bigger
tree, at least as big.
It doesn't even need
to be strictly bigger.
So certainly, Nh minus 1
is greater than or equal
to Nh minus 2.
Now, this is 2 times Nh minus 2.
And this is an easy recurrence.
This is just powers of 2.
I keep multiplying by 2,
and subtracting 2 from h.
So this solves to
2 to the h over 2,
maybe with a floor or something.
But I'm using a base case here,
which is N sub 0 equals 1.
Maybe it's a ceiling then.
But the point is
this is exponential.
So this implies that the height
is always, at most, 2 times
log n.
This 2 corresponds to this 2.
If you just invert
this formula, this
was a number of nodes is
going to be at least 2
to the h over 2.
And so h is, at most, 2 log n.
So it's not log n.
That would be perfect.
But it's within a
factor of 2 of log n.
So AVL trees are
always quite balanced.
Number of levels
is at most double
what you need to store n nodes.
Great.
We're left with the main magic--
not domain magic.
That's different.
And let's see, we're going
to use subtree augmentation.
Keep that.
Big remaining
challenge is how do we
maintain this high balance
property using rotations?
We have all the ingredients
lined up for us.
We have subtree augmentation.
What does that let me do?
It's relevant to AVL trees.
Well, it lets me store height.
I need to be able to compute
the height of a node.
That, in general,
takes linear time,
because I have to look at
all the downward paths--
all the leaves
within that subtree.
But height is a
subtree property--
so, yes-- height.
Why?
Because-- let me
just write it here--
node.height equals 1 plus
max of node.left.height
and node.right.height
and of max.
Let me put this in a box.
This equation, or I guess
it's an assignment operation--
this is a 1--
is the thing we've been
doing over and over.
When I said what is the
height of this node,
you just figured
that out, right?
You took the height of
the left subtree maxed
with the height of
the right subtree
and added 1 to account
for these edges.
So this is a
general update rule.
It matches this subtree
property pattern.
If I have the property
of left and right,
I can compute it for node.
And this takes
constant time to do.
And so it's a subtree property.
And so I can maintain, through
all the things I'm doing,
the height of every node.
Oh by the way, whenever
I do a rotation,
I'm also going to have to
update my subtree properties.
When I rotate this edge, A does
not change, B does not change,
C does not change.
So that's good.
But x's subtree changes.
It now has y.
It didn't before.
So we're going to have to also
update the augmentation here
in y.
And we're going to have to
update the augmentation in x.
And we're going
to have to update
the augmentation of all of
the ancestors of x eventually.
So rotation is
locally just changing
a constant number of pointers.
So I usually think of rotations
as taking constant time.
But eventually, we
will have to do--
this is constant time locally.
But we will need to update
h ancestors in order
to store all of-- keep all of
our augmentations up to date.
We'll worry about that later.
All right, so great.
Now we have the height
of all the nodes.
We can compute the skew
of all the nodes, cool.
We have this rotation operation.
And we want to maintain this
height balance property.
Height of left node-- left
and right of every node--
is plus or minus 1, or 0.
Cool, so I said over here
somewhere, whenever we--
so the only things
that change the tree
are when we insert
or delete a new node.
And the way that we
implemented those so far
is to add or remove a leaf.
So we should still be thinking
about adding or removing
a leaf.
The problem is, when
I add a new leaf,
now maybe this tree is
higher than it used to be.
So some node here may no
longer be height balanced.
But because height is
a subtree property,
the only nodes we
need to check are
the ones up this ancestor path.
And there's only log n of them,
because now height is log n.
That's what we just proved as
long as we have this property.
Now, we right now don't
have it for, like,
maybe these few nodes.
But it was long n before.
It's at most log n--
2 log n plus 1 right now,
because we just added a node.
So what I want to do is
check all of these ancestor
nodes in sequence from
bottom up, and find
one that's out of balance.
So let's take the lowest
out of balance node.
I'm going to call that x.
Now, because we just insert
or deleted a single leaf,
it's only out of balance
by 1, because we only
changed height--
one height went up by 1, or
one height went down by 1.
And before, all of our skews
were plus or minus 1, or 0.
So now, it's-- the bad case
is when it's plus or minus 2.
If it happens to still be in
this range for all the nodes,
we're happy.
But if it's outside this range,
it's only going to be out by 1.
So this means the skew
is n plus 2 or minus 2.
And let's say that
it's 2 by symmetry.
So my picture is--
I'm going to draw
double right arrow
to say that this subtree is
2 higher than this subtree.
OK, so that's bad and
we want to fix it.
The obvious thing to do
is to rotate this edge.
Because that'll make this--
this is too high
and this is too low.
So if we rotate, this
should go down by 1
and this should go up by 1.
And that works most of the time.
So case one is the skew of y.
What is y?
I want y to be the
right child of x.
Because we have a positive skew,
we know there is a right child.
Now, because this was
the lowest bad node,
we know that y is actually good.
It's either right heavy--
or even the two subtrees
have the same height--
or left heavy.
The easy cases
are when skew of y
is either 1 or 0,
which I will draw.
So a double right arrow,
let's say single right arrow--
so I'm just going to
add some labels here
to make this
picture consistent--
k plus 1, k plus 2.
I'm riding the heights.
So this is an example
where C is taller
than B. A and B are
the same height.
And then if you compute
the heights up here,
indeed this one
is right leaning.
This one is doubly
right leaning.
Because this one
has height k plus 1.
This one has height k minus 1.
That's bad.
But if we do this
right rotation on x,
we get exactly what we want.
So I'm just going to copy
the labels on A, B, C--
we have k minus 1,
k minus 1, and k--
and then recompute.
That means this
guy has height k,
this one has height k plus 1.
And now, all the nodes in this
picture that I've highlighted--
A, B, and C haven't changed.
They were height
balanced before.
They still are.
But now, x and y--
x wasn't height
balanced before, y was.
Now, both x and y
are height balanced.
That's case one.
In case two, the
skew of y is flat,
which means that this
is a k, and this is a k,
and this is a k plus 1,
and this is a k plus 2.
But still, all the
nodes are balanced--
height balanced.
They're still plus or minus 1.
So those are the easy cases.
Unfortunately, there
is a hard case--
case three.
But there's only one, and
it's not that much harder.
So it's when skew
of y is minus 1.
In this case, we need to
look at the left child of y.
And to be alphabetical, I'm
going to rename this to z.
So this one, again,
is double right arrow.
This one is now left arrow.
And this is letter y.
And so we have A, B, C, and D
potential subtrees hanging off
of them.
And I'm going to label the
heights of these things.
These are each k
minus 1 or k minus 2.
This one's k minus 1.
And now, compute the inside.
So this is going to height k
for this to be left leaning.
So this is k plus 1,
and this is k plus 2.
But the problem is this
is 2 higher than this.
The height of z is 2 higher
than the height of A.
This case, if I
do this rotation,
things get worse, actually.
I'll just tell you the
right thing to do is--
this is the one thing
you need to memorize.
And let me draw the results.
You can also just think of it
as redrawing the tree like this.
But it's easier from
an analysis perspective
to think about it
as two rotations.
Then we can just reduce.
As long as we know
how rotations work,
then we know that
this thing works--
"works" meaning it
preserves traversal order
and we can maintain
all the augmentations.
So now, if I copy over these
labels-- the height labels--
I have k minus 1.
I have, for these two guys,
k minus 1 or k minus 2.
The biggest one is k minus 1.
This is k minus 1.
And so this will be k.
This will be k.
This will be k plus 1.
And lo and behold, we have
a nice, height balanced tree
in all three cases
for this one node.
Now, this was the lowest node.
Once we update
this one, it could
be that we changed the
height of the root.
Before it was k plus
2, now it's k plus 1.
Or sometimes, we keep it the
same, like over in this case.
And so now, we have
to check the parent.
Maybe the parent
is out of balance.
And we just keep
walking up the node,
and also maintain all the
augmentations as we go.
Then, we'll keep track of
height and subtree size
if we want them, or any
other augmentations.
And after order h
operations, we will
have restored height
balanced property, which
means all the way through,
h equals order log n.
And so all of our operations
now are magically order log n.